niant la campagne présidentielle à
nouveau taux du sport raymond barre ce
soir à marseille c'était le meeting le
plus important monsieur bart devant près
de dix mille personnes a beaucoup parlé
de l'immigration bien sûr et il s'en est
pris avec pugnacité au candidat
mitterrand reportage à marseille olivier
lerner j moins trente 30 jours
d'offensive tous azimuts pour raymond
barre qui entame comme les autres
candidats sa dernière ligne droite
un raymond barre particulièrement
qu'alain vis-à-vis de jacques chirac et
du gouvernement chirac mais durs très
durs à l'égard de françois mitterrand un
raymond barre qui a bien mal digéré la
déclaration de candidature du chef de
l'état en tout cas le voilà président
candidat pour quoi faire
eh bien figurez-vous que la paix sociale
et la paix civile sont menacés je
circule beaucoup en france vous aussi
tous mes collègues qui viennent de
régions voisines qui me font le gros
revers d'être lâche sont promenés
aujourd'hui sur les routes de france
il n'y a pas eu le sentiment sauf
quelques mouvements de grève sous là que
la paix sociale ni la paix civile se
pouvait menacer
eh bien je dis que monsieur mitterrand
n'est pas crédible
en tout cas l'occasion nous est offerte
peut lui donner congé
raymond barre a fait savoir qu'il
souhaitait affronter françois mitterrand
dans un débat télévisé entre les deux
tours habile pirouette pour qui n'aurait
pas compris qu'ils se voient déjà
qualifié pour le second tour à marseille
sous le soleil
raymond barre s'est repris à espérer
dans cette campagne la journée a été
marquée par les prises de position de
monsieur bart et chirac à propos de
l'appreil 8 mai en cas de victoire de
françois mitterrand
bach a dit qu'il ne censurez pas
automatiquement un gouvernement désigné
par le candidat socialiste
al'inverse de chirac